كان بنيامين نتنياهو القوة الأكثر
هيمنة في السياسة الإسرائيلية
لعقود من الزمن ،
فقد كان رئيس وزراء إسرائيل
على مدى السنوات الـ 12 الماضية ، وقضى فترة
ثلاث سنوات إضافية في أواخر التسعينيات ، لكن
عهد نتنياهو قد يقترب من نهايته لأن الائتلاف قد اقترب من نهايته.
يجري تشكيلها
الآن للإطاحة به للانضمام إلي الآن هو توم
فريدمان الذي كان ذات يوم
رئيس مكتب القدس في نيويورك تايمز
وهو الآن كاتب عمود للشؤون الخارجية في
الصحيفة ومؤلف كتاب
من بيروت إلى القدس ،
دعونا نفترض في البداية أن
من يعرف أين  يحدث هذا لأنه
ستكون
هناك حاجة لوجود سبع اتفاقيات ائتلافية
، وسينظر محامو السائل في هذا الأمر ،
بل ربما يذهبون إلى المحكمة لأنه ليس من
الواضح أنه كان من
الممكن أن يكون بينيت رئيسًا للوزراء
إذا طلب الرئيس لبيد
لذلك هناك الكثير من التعقيد
وقد يتأرجح هذا الأمر على مدار أيام ،
لكن ماذا يعني إذا
انتهى حقبة بيبي نتنياهو
إذا انتهى حقبة
الأمم المتحدة الوطنية؟  حكومة المدينة في إسرائيل ، اسمحوا
لي أن أصفها بعبارات
يمكن للأمريكيين أن يفهموا أن هذا هو نزعة بادينية
إلى إسرائيل ،
إنها رد فعل عنيف ضد
زعيم طور عبادة شخصية
عاشت أساسًا من خلال تقسيم الناس
أم أه الذي كان أمه
فاسدًا للغاية يُزعم أنه موجود الآن  محاكمة
لثلاث قضايا فساد
أه هو انتصار الأشخاص الذين
يؤمنون
بالمؤسسات بسيادة القانون واللياقة ،
إنها بداية
محتملة للرد العنيف في إسرائيل ،
لكن دعني أسألك توم عندما تنظر إلى
بعض الشخصيات الرئيسية هنا ،
نفتالي بينيت هو  شخص ما فيما
يتعلق بقضية إسرائيل ، أعتقد
أنه من العدل أن نقول
إنه أكثر تشددًا من نتنياهو ، قال
إنه لن يتخلى عن
الضفة الغربية أبدًا ، لقد تحدث عن الطريقة التي
أخذ بها أه تعلم أنه لم ير شيئًا خطأ
في قتل العرب ،
لديك متعطش ليبرمان أه  جزء من
الائتلاف أعتقد أنه يمكنك
القول بشكل معقول أن ليبرمان يدعو إلى
التطهير العرقي للفلسطينيين الذين ينقلون
الفلسطينيين
الذين هم حتى مواطنون إسرائيليون  في بعض
الحالات خارج الأرض ،
ما الذي يخبرنا به ذلك كيف
يجب أن تعرف هل
يجب أن نرحب بهذا حقًا ، لذلك أعتقد
أنه إذا كنت تعتقد أن هذا هو
مقدمة للسلام الإسرائيلي الفلسطيني ،
بالطبع هذا ليس هو  القضية
أم
ولكن ما كان بينيت
مدافعًا قويًا عن فريد
هو استقلالية قوية جدًا
للفلسطينيين
في الضفة الغربية وأعتقد أنه يمكنك
رؤية
إجماع يتشكل في هذا الائتلاف الجديد
هذا تحالف الوحدة الوطنية المحتمل
أه حول المزيد من الانفصال والمزيد من
الحكم الذاتي لـ  الفلسطينيون في الضفة الغربية
كنقطة انطلاق محتملة
لشيء آخر الآن حرروا
أهم شيء للدبلوماسية الأمريكية
والسياسة الإسرائيلية هو الحفاظ على
شيء واحد على قيد الحياة
والآن هو حقًا أه في
العناية المركزة حل الدولتين
وأنا أرى  هذا التحالف على الأقل من
المحتمل
أن يفعل ذلك لأنني أعتقد أن هناك
قاسمًا مشتركًا
للانفصال وللحكم الذاتي الفلسطيني الحقيقي
ما لم يتم نزع الشرعية اليومية عن
السلطة الفلسطينية
التي كانت عنصرًا أساسيًا في
سياسة
نتنياهو لقد غطيت الشرق الأوسط لمدة
30 عامًا
عندما كتبت من بيروت إلى القدس ،
فأنت تعلم أنك
كنت متفائلًا جدًا بشأن
حل الدولتين الذي دافعت عنه حتى ذلك
الحين في هذه المرحلة.  عندما تنظر
إلى التعدي على المستوطنات عندما
تنظر إلى تطرف السياسة الإسرائيلية
عندما تنظر إلى
الدرجة التي تعرف أن
الخلل الوظيفي لا يزال يحكم غزة من قبل
حماس ،
هل تفهم جيدًا ،
هل تفهم وتعتقد أنه سيكون هناك  كن
جاذباً لهذه
الفكرة التي تراها تنمو على
الجانب الفلسطيني ومع بعض
أه الصهاينة الليبراليين مثل بيتر بينارت
ربما يكون الحل الوحيد هنا هو دولة
واحدة ثنائية
القومية حيث تمنح
الفلسطينيين أه
حقوقهم السياسية  داخل إسرائيل ،
لا أرى حقًا حدوث ذلك ،
أعتقد أن أفضل ما يمكن أن تتمناه ،
أعتقد أننا في واقع الدولة الواحدة
أكثر مما نحن فيه  واقع الدولتين
ولكني لا أراه على أنه واقع دولة واحدة
تمنح فيه الأغلبية اليهودية أساسًا
أه المساواة الكاملة للأقلية الفلسطينية أه
إذا أحضرت
مليونين ونصف المليون فلسطيني
من الغرب  البنك
أه لكني أعتقد أننا في مرحلة
حيث المخاطر التي تتعرض لها إسرائيل من أن تصبح
دولة فصل عنصري
أه أصبحت واضحة جدًا وقد أصبح واضحًا
في الأسبوعين الماضيين هنا
حررتك كما تعلم ، وربما نشهد في
جو بايدن الأخير  يقول الرئيس الديمقراطي المؤيد لإسرائيل
إذا نظرت إلى مكان
اليسار الصاعد في ذلك الحزب اليوم
، وبالتالي أعتقد أنك سترى
تحركًا أقوى نحو بناء المزيد من
الانفصال
وخلق حكم ذاتي أقوى بكثير
والحفاظ على إمكانية
حل الدولتين على ما
أعتقد  هذا هو أقصى ما يمكن أن
نأمله الآن ولكني أعتقد أن هذا
احتمال مع هذا التحالف الجديد